Hmm, let's see, let me make some first name
Let's see, maybe last name
Oh just .. oh, oh, hello! I'm just making some
JSON here! Now I've made this JSON object,
question comes to mind: if that's the format I
love to work in, what is the best data store to
handle JSON objects? Hello, my name is Jamil
Spain, Brand Technical Specialist with the
US Financial Services Market. Today I want
to talk through when making that decision,
not the front-end, not the back-end, but for the
database layer in your application architecture.
If you love working with JSON which database of
choice should you use? Today's topic is MongoDB
being that choice. Now as a technologist often when
we evaluate technology we ought to have some type
of criteria to make our decisions against. Here
I have my chosen 3 that I like to do when
it comes to evaluating technology - the flexibility,
how easy easy is it to implement, and also at some
point once we start having fun behind the keyboard
we got to consider the deployment aspect here. I've
already started here with the JSON object. So as
you can see and guess, MongoDB is great for storing
NoSQL data structures. Meaning it's not, you
know, built to be, I don't have to define the
structure up front, I can take a JSON object,
a document, that really has no structure
any number of fields, and it's great to
store that. Then it also is an in memory
data store.
So all the objects that I store are located
in memory processed there which means I have
relatively easy access to get to those as
well. These JSON documents can be any kind
of size here. One caveat that I have learned from
working with this and leveraging Mongo to store
my documents here is be conscious of sometimes
we have a tendency with JSON to not have a set
number of fields. And that can become a problem,
you may want to make placeholders for null values,
or define some type of consistency here as well.
One other great feature that I've noticed is if I
were to add a longitude, latitude to my JSON object,
Mongo is great for querying, doing geospatial
queries against these data sets as well. So, if I wanted to make my own type of let's say a food
delivery service and I wanted to determine which
locations were closest to you. If I have the users,
me Spain here, actual longitude latitude
coordinates I could compare that against
the other JSON documents that may also include
the same type of information here as well.
All right, I think we've covered this. Let's put
a check mark next to flexibility here as well.
Now when it comes to implementation, yes, you got
to make sure that all the SDKs are available, are
are there any limitations that you have to account for.
So of course, there is JavaScript, there's Java,
Golang, there's pretty much all the the value
pairs are there. Theres the popular languages are
are there for you to use, and easy examples
client libraries to actually access this as
well. So not a consideration from there. Let's
talk about deployment for a second after I do
that check mark on implementation here. Therefore
deployment, you can set up MongoDB relatively, I
want to say easily, but it does, there are easy
ways to facilitate, whether it's on containers or
maybe on your own Linux servers. You can set up an
easy instance without security, very easy to play
with. So for development, I would say yes it's very
easy to set up a single instance and prove out how
easy it is to implement into your architecture
whether you're architecting for web or mobile
and what you're working with. And for production
purposes, once you get that exciting architecture
set up here, you will have the ability, it works off
the same what I like to call "main and secondary
models". So you have a main node that you publish
to or interact with and it can do the replication
to those secondaries.
So scaling that way on more of a horizontal scale
to meet the demand of your actual architecture
there. So that can really be useful if
you want it to be your primary database
to function with, and as we know JSON is becoming
a pretty popular standard to to work with your
data structures there. So, we'll do the check mark
there. So, hopefully it's been useful. There's much,
much more, we're just touching the surface here, but
I want you to definitely go out to mongodb.org and
look out for more information. Thank you for your
time. If you have questions, please drop us a line
below. And if you want to see more videos like
this in the future, please like and subscribe.